welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's one division has been
promising to launch a new
era of the mcu with a series of social
media posters reflecting its decade
shifting release state teaser probably
building up to a final trailer in the
coming days
as one of the most cryptic titles on
marvel's phase 4 lineup
each drip of detail from this series is
worth diving head first into and once
you know it there's actually
a ton of clues hidden in these images
weird patterns and
inconsistencies that actually connect to
the other details we know about this
series
i'm gonna break down everything we
learned from these with another tweet
down
and yeah it does look like marvel is
releasing these daily and by the time
you're watching this there may be
another update
and i'll be out with another video
covering all the new stuff that comes
out don't worry and this video is
brought to you by privacy
privacy lets you buy things online using
virtual cards protecting your identity
and bank information on the internet and
as a treat for my viewers new customers
get five dollars to spend on their first
purchase when they go to privacy.com
new rockstars to sign up now but let us
start with the december 4th poster
this depicts what looks like a late 50s
tv set this would be kind of a luxury
model for the 1950s a lot of tv sets
back then were heavier boxes with
way smaller screens wanda envision are
depicted on a screen in what looks like
their 50s sitcom life inspired perhaps
by i love lucy now the wallpaper peels
away to reveal blue and pink static
kind of similar to one of those 3d magic
eye patterns as if to suggest this
false sitcom reality is peeling away to
reveal a vibrant technicolor multiverse
of static
that static being the kind of membrane
between each medium
as the channels flicker to each new
reality in wanda's mind this actually
matches the way monica rambo
passed through that barrier of wanda's
pocket reality in the trailer with that
barrier emitting the same kind of
staticky glow but onto the december 5th
poster
wallpaper peels back exactly the same
except now
the set around it has changed the tv is
now on a brass rolling cart and on that
screen
looks like a 1960s sitcom the dick van
dyke show which we have learned it was a
reference point because dick van dyke
himself consulted on the series we could
also be looking at some influences from
bewitched as well
a top hat rests atop the tv that top hat
was only
partially visible before it vanished in
the november teaser now to me this
suggests the kind of magic
act of this show a magic man in his
lovely assistant
or a magic woman in her lovely assistant
pulling back the curtain to reveal a
kind
of slight of hand so not necessarily
true sorcery but trickery also notice
how vision now proudly exists in his
android form as opposed to his human
flesh version of himself in the 50s
world poster the potted plant on the
left has evolved from a croton
to a rubber tree plant and framed on the
wall is a painting of pink roses one of
them fall into the table surface now
things get a bit more interesting as we
move on to the december 6th poster
the plant stays the same though in a
basket now the tv set has also evolved
to a
color set so with the dials though wanda
and vision on screen are in the 70s
sitcom versions that we've seen in
trailers with a set modeled on the brady
bunch
because wanda's got some major marsha
brady hair there
this is the setting when wanda first
appears pregnant in the other footage
we've seen
keep that in mind now the tv rabbit ears
have been knocked askew
to the 11 o'clock and 10 o'clock angles
and now the peeling wallpaper
has a big old bite taken out of that
wood paneling
this to me is a bit creepy as if some
beast from beyond
is tearing into this setting the way
poltergeists use a tv screen as a medium
between dimensions
localized within an idyllic suburban
home that brings us to the december 7th
poster we're back with the peeling
wallpaper but the tv set has advanced to
a
silver one rabbit ears still a skew but
the dials are gone
in their place channel buttons it's the
80s baby and we're getting fancy the set
shows one to envision in an 80s sitcom
looks a lot like family ties it's also
possible we'll get a nod to the sitcom
of elizabeth olsen's big sister's full
house
but that was kind of an 80s to 90s
sitcom another trailer footage wanda
envisioned have their twins now but
interestingly then
vision was in his red android form so
here he is a
dude with a crappy haircut but all over
this set are some pretty big changes
the plant has now moved to the right
it's on a stool and it's now a boston
fern but really the big easter egg
is in these two bird pictures if you can
identify what species there are there
are some important clues there
and again thanks to privacy for
sponsoring this video as we are still in
the midst of the holiday shopping season
make sure your online purchases are
secure
and no or mick identity theft steals
your info
use your privacy card to reduce any risk
or concern with giving your financial
information online
see privacy comes in handy with
streaming services and video
conferencing apps other subscription
services
i've set up an account with privacy
linked my bank account created a card
specifically for my monthly netflix
subscription payment privacy will
ding you if someone tries to charge that
card twice or if the charge exceeds the
amount you set for it
or if you like forgot to cancel your
subscription payment but already preset
that card you're not going to
accidentally get charged for something
you don't want
you can fill out your credit card info
in the privacy.com chrome and firefox
extension and you're only ever one click
away from spending smartly and safely
privacy also protects your identity and
your bank information on the internet
and it lets you control the limits of
each virtual card
you can connect directly to your bank
account with confidence no vendor
can overcharge beyond the limit that you
have set it is simple it's fast it's
just one click it's
awesome just head to privacy.com new
rockstars and sign up for an account
and as a special treat for my viewers
new customers will automatically get
five dollars to spend on your first
purchase that is an amazing deal money
you can spend right now just go to
privacy.com
new rockstars and sign up now okay these
birds the top one with the orange wings
and the beautiful blue tail feathers is
a phoenix chicken it's a german
crossbreed from the japanese
onagadori which is thought to have a
recessive gene that prevents it from
molting normally
there is definitely a parallel between
this bird and
a being like vision also a crossbreed
also a colorful fella who doesn't
transition his outer colors in the
normal way and yeah a metaphorical
phoenix
resurrecting from his own ashes in
infinity war now the lower bird is a
variegated
fairy wren an eastern australian bird
with lovely plumage
if we assume this bird represents wanda
there's totally a parallel with the way
this bird's colors clash and patches and
streaks
the way wanda's variegated realities
chaotically clash
and spill into each other by the way big
thanks to our friends in new rockstars
discord for helping me id these birds dr
zoidberg new master 68
mezzo jd and syndro and lots of others
thank you all so much let's all play
wingspan someday shall we
and then onto the december 8th poster
there's a 90s set
with that same black 4x3 screen that we
all had in the 90s a jack-o-lantern rest
atop the tv and they are wearing their
halloween costumes that depict them in
the classic marvel comics costumes
and while no rabbit ears there is a
clicker now remote control channel
changer wherever you live
and it is thrown on the ground chaos but
more importantly
more bird imagery that we gotta talk
about here a nest with not
two but three eggs we only saw two kids
before folks
so to me this implies that there could
be a third
presence that is sneaking just behind
these first two babies but not a third
kid
just a little stowaway who's trying to
sneak his way into this reality
so what have we learned from all these
posters well to me the most interesting
detail other than those birds i love
birds
is the violent chunk torn into the set
wall
of the 70s set the same decade when it
appears juan
becomes pregnant are these two arrivals
linked because to me this could be a
clue hinting towards this idea that
wanda envisions children are not the
blessings from god that you might expect
but hellspawn cursed upon this pocket
reality
by the demonic beast trying to claw
his way into this plane of existence
using these children as
his conduits the way and poltergeist
poor caroline was hijacked for her life
force
so that beast could try to cross back
over into the world of the living but in
the world of marvel i'm speaking of
course of mephisto
marvel's satanic entity who has not yet
explicitly revealed himself in these
posters or footage but
mephisto could be that third egg people
what an easter egg that would be
mephisto ties heavily into the scarlet
witch comics i believe they're actually
pulling from
maybe not house of m necessarily yet but
in this series
the west coast avengers comics from the
80s which showed wanda envisioned in the
costumes we now see in this series
dealing with babies and with the witch
agatha harkness kind of like the
character agnes
in this show as those kids are revealed
to be false puppets controlled by
mephisto as a way to steal wanda's chaos
magic
i suspect everything we are seeing in
one division is part of that plot by
mephisto in the mcu maybe even played by
evan peters
i mean if we want to get technical about
it mephisto does already exist in canon
in the mcu his name appeared
just fairly visible on nick fury's
shield document that he handed a cap
back in the first avengers assuming
those shield records are now part of the
investigation run by
sword the sentient world they're
observing and responding to
could be hell with wanda's pocket
reality being the gateway between hell
and our world now we will be getting
more updates on division in the coming
days i'll be covering all of it on this
channel with breakdowns and
a weekly after show so subscribe hit
that notification bell to get all the
updates you can also support this
channel by checking out all of our great
merch options at newarkstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram
eaboss follow new rockstars thank you
for watching see you next time bye
[Music]
you